emilie est coiffeuse à montigny le
bretonneux depuis plus de dix ans cela
fait même plusieurs années et qu'elle
gère son propre famille mais il ya
quelques mois emilie a découvert
l'univers de la télévision en
travaillant sur les missions de la star
academy pour changer du quotidien
travaillant au salon c'est une
expérience sympa que je pense beaucoup
de coiffeurs aimerait faire pendant
laquelle leur carrière c'est différent
parce que là on travaille quand même
beaucoup en équipe que l'on un salon on
est individuellement sur notre client là
en bon voilà on a les consignes on peut
être à deux sur une même personne c'est
sympa parce qu'on se dit qu'on va de
notre coiffure va passer à la télé donc
on est assez fiers de ça emilie
intervient sur les primes du jeudi soir
au sein d'une équipe d'une dizaine de
coiffeurs coupent couleurs brushing
extension toutes les techniques sont
employés pour respecter les instructions
de la production je coiffe et qui je
veux rominger en sommes j'ai coiffé
profs aussi les deux femmes un prof sans
oublier vanina candidates venant de
versailles et midi qui officie dans les
coulisses de la star academy n'a pas été
recruté par la production et par
l'entreprise générique basée dans les
yvelines partenaires coiffeur sur
l'émission de télé réalité ils
fournissent au programme les produits
capillaires et des équipes de
professionnels tout au début il y avait
quinze candidats donc effectivement on
était une dizaine
ce jeudi-là y avait combien de coffres
alors là on était sept 7 coiffeur et
fini normalement à 3,4 sauf pour le
dernier prime ou là où tous les
candidats vont revenir
donc là on va être à nouveau je pense à
peu près une dizaine de profaner le
budget investi par l'entreprise
générique pour cette publicité se
chiffrent à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros
mais la retombée sur leurs clients
professionnels et surtout particulier
est déjà très positive